MEMBERS AND GUESTS PLEASE
WELCOME THE FORTY OF GOVERNOR OF
THE GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THE HONORABLE GAVIN NEWSOM
.
WE HAVE SEVERAL ON OUR GUESTS
TODAY PLEASE WELCOME THE FIRST
PARTNER JENNIFER SIEBEL NEWSOM
.
THE CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICERS FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR LANEY COULD
UNLOCK THIS.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL I'VE EVER
SARAH.
THE CONTROLLER BETTY.
THE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND.
THE INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
RICARDO LARA.
FROM THE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION
FROM DISTRICT ONE TED GAINES.
THE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION
DISTRICTS TO MALINA CURRENT.
WHEN THE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION
DISTRICTS THREE TONY VASQUEZ?
IN ORDER IT WAS ATION DISTRICT
FOR MIKE SCHAFER.
WELCOME THE CHIEF JUSTICES OF
THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT TO
THE KITCHEN CHIEF JUSTICE A
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT.
TINY COUNTY --
SOCCERWAY.
ASSOCIATE JUSTICE MEAN CHEN.
AS SOON AS YOU JUSTICE CAROL
CORRIGAN.
THIS ISSUE JUSTICE GOODWIN LIU.
ASSOCIATE JUSTICE MARIANO
FLORENTINO CHOIR.
ASSOCIATE JUSTICE LEE UNDER THE
ANDREA KRUGER.
HE'S WELCOME ASSOCIATE JUSTICE
JOSHUA ROAD. ONE AND WELCOME OUR
CONSULAR CORPS THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE.
AND I ALSO WANT TO WELCOME AND
WELCOME ALL OF OUR OTHER
DISTINGUISHED PUBLIC OFFICIALS
AND SPECIAL GUESTS THAT'S ALL OF
YOU THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
SO ALMOST ONE YEAR AGO --
AFTER SENATOR TONI ATKINS BECAME
SENATOR PRO TEM AND THIS IS THAT
THE PROGRAM'S FIRST STATE OF THE
STATUS PROGRAM AND WE KNOW ALL
KNOW HOW HAPPY I AM TO HAVE HER
HERE -- WE
JOINTLY SIGNED AN OPINION PIECE
IN A THAT WE WE HAVE A LOT OF
WORK TO DO.
BUT THAT WE WOULD BE DOING IT
TOGETHER.
WE SAID IT'S NOT ABOUT WINNING A
COMPETITION IT'S ABOUT WINNING
GAMES FOR THE PEOPLE THAT WE
REPRESENT.
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
ALL OF THEM.
I'M SURE THAT --
CENTER ATKINS JOINS ME IN
SIGNING ON IN SIGNING ANOTHER
PIECE.
WELCOMING GAVIN NEWSOM TO OUR TO
HE SHARES ARE PROGRESSIVE VALUES
AND OUR COMMITMENT TO MAKING
CALIFORNIA BETTER FOR ALL OF HIS
RESIDENCE.
I CONGRATULATE HIM AND LOOK
FORWARD TO HIS FIRST STATE OF
THE STATE ADDRESS.
I KNOW WE CAN ALSO CANONISED
EXCESSIVE AS LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
OF ANY COULD LOCK IS.
NOW IT IS MY PLEASURE TO
INTRODUCE THE PRESIDENT PRO TEM
OF THE CALIFORNIA SENATE.
THE HONORABLE TONI ATKINS.
IT IS SO WONDERFUL TO BE BACK IN
THIS HOUSE TODAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
MISTER SPEAKER FOR HOSTING US
FROM THE SENATE AND FOR YOUR
PARTNERSHIP.
I IT IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT ON
BEHALF OF OUR GREAT STATE SO
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
IT'S AN HONOR TO BE ABLE TO
INTRODUCE CALIFORNIA'S
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR THE FIRST
WOMAN ELECTED TO SERVE IN THAT
POSITION.
AND I'M GRATEFUL FOR HER
COMMITMENT TO CALIFORNIA'S WORLD
CLASS INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
LEARNING.
AND IS THE REPRESENTATIVE OF
SEVERAL COMMUNITIES THAT DEPEND
ON OUR COAST I'M GRATEFUL FOR
THE STRONG VOICE THAT SHE WILL
BRING TO THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION.
AT TIMES LIKE THIS IN THE
HISTORY OF AMERICA IT'S HARD TO
SHAKE THE FEELING.
AS JOAN DIDION SAID THINGS IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE HERE IS WHERE
WE RUN OUT OF CONTINENT.
SO WITH OUR NEW GOVERNOR AT THE
HELM AND OUR STEAM SENATE
PRESIDENT AND LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR I YOU HEARD ME SAY A
STEAM SENATE PRESIDENT.
AND LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR IN
SUPPORT I'M CONFIDENT THAT WE
HAVE THE LEADERSHIP TO ENSURE
THAT THINGS KEEP WORKING BETTER
HERE.
SO PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING
THE HONORABLE LANEY UNA LAKIS
.
PRESIDENT PRO TEMPORE THAT WARM
AND GRACIOUS INTRODUCTION.
LOOKING AROUND THIS CHAMBER
THERE IS SO MUCH TO BE PROUD OUT.
EVERY YEAR CALIFORNIA'S ELECTED
OFFICIALS LOOK MORE AND MORE
LIKE THE PEOPLE WE REPRESENT.
THIS YEAR.
THERE ARE MORE.
THERE ARE MORE WOMEN.
AND MORE PARENTS WITH SMALL KIDS
AND BIG IDEAS.
CHANGE IS IN THE AIR ALONG WITH
GREAT ANTICIPATION.
OF WHAT WE WILL DO TOGETHER TO
MEET THE CHALLENGES OF THE
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY.
OVER THE PAST TWENTY MONTHS I'VE
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO TRAVEL TO
ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES.
ASKING QUESTIONS AND LISTENING
TO PEOPLE FROM ALL WALKS OF LIFE.
WE KNOW THAT SINCE THE END OF
THE GREAT RECESSION CALIFORNIA
HAS REBOUNDED TO BECOME THE
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD.
EMPLOYMENT IS AT A RECORD LOW
GDP GROWTH IS OUT PACING MOST OF
THE COUNTRY AND WE HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT BUDGET SURPLUS.
BUT TRAVELED THE STATE I MET
MANY FAMILIES WHO ARE STILL OUT
THERE STRIVING TO REBUILD THEIR
ECONOMIC SECURITY.
AND REGAIN WHAT THEY LOST DURING
THE RECESSION.
I WAS INSPIRED BY A PROFOUND
SENSE NOT OF EXASPERATION BUT OF
HOPE.
AND EXPECTATION OF HOPE THAT IS
CALIFORNIA'S DEMOCRATICALLY
ELECTED REPRESENTATIVES WE HEAR
THEM.
AND AN EXPECTATION THAT WE WILL
TO KEEP THE CALIFORNIA DREAM
ALIVE FOR EVERYONE.
CALIFORNIANS ARE LOOKING TO ALL
OF US AND ESPECIALLY TO OUR
NEWLY ELECTED GOVERNOR AND FIRST
PARTNER.
YOUR BOLD LEADERSHIP IN JUST
THESE FIRST WEEKS HAS ALREADY
AFFECTED THE NATIONAL DIALOGUE
ON ISSUES LIKE BORDER SECURITY
AND HUMAN RIGHTS.
AND YOUR FIRST PROPOSED BUDGET
UNDERSCORES A COMMITMENT TO
FISCAL RESPONSIBILITY A
COMMITMENT TO OUR CHILDREN.
OUR ENVIRONMENT OUR WORLD
RENOWNED SYSTEM OF PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION AND SO MUCH MORE.
WHICH IS WHY WE ARE HERE TODAY
FOR YOUR VERY FIRST STATE OF
THIS DAY.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IT IS MY
HONOR AND PRIVILEGE TO INTRODUCE
THE FORTIETH GOVERNOR OF THE
GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA PLEASE
STAND FOR GOVERNOR GAVIN
[inaudible]
OVER UNDER.
SOMEONE SAID TWO HOURS OR ONE I
SAID IN A BIG ONE WE'RE GONNA BE
ALRIGHT BUT I WANT TO THANK ALL
OF YOU.
FOR THE GENEROSITY OF SPIRIT I
WANT TO THANK.
MISTER SPEAKER YOU IN PARTICULAR --
FOR BEING A CHAMPION NOT ONLY
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS BUT BEAN --
AN EXTRAORDINARY COURAGEOUS
LEADER AND AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR GENEROSITY OF
WELCOMING MYSELF AND MY WIFE.
INTO YOUR HOUSE TO DATA.
THAT A PRO TEM THANK YOU.
FOR YOUR COMMITMENT.
TO PERHAPS MORE ANYTHING ELSE
COLLABORATION WHAT I THINK IS
REALLY HELP MAKE THIS FIRST
MONTH TOGETHER --
SO REMARKABLY PRODUCTIVE --
AND IT IS A NICE THING TO SAY
FOR THE FIRST TIME EVER.
I GET TO SAY IN THIS CHAMBER
THANK YOU MADAM LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR FOR THAT INTERACTION --
WHAT?
WITH.
THE KNOWLEDGE THE LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR.
TO YOU KNOW.
SOMEONE IS NOT ALWAYS THE CASE
WE GOTTA REMEMBER OUR OUR STATUS.
AND ALL THE CONSTITUTIONAL
OFFICERS I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE TODAY ON THE
LEGISLATORS AND ALL THE ELECTED
OFFICIALS THAT --
I SEE UP THERE THEY TRAVEL
ACROSS THE STATE TO BE HERE I'M
A MEASURE OF THE GRATEFUL AND
HUMBLE -- BY
YOUR PRESENCE HERE TODAY AND IT
JUST SO YOU'RE.
REASSURED DO NOT WORRY DUTCH IS
NOT HERE TODAY --
WE OULD CLEARLY LEARNED OUR
LESSON FROM THE INAUGURAL I I
KNOW.
YEAH YOU'RE GONNA BE STUCK
HAVING TO PAY ATTENTION TO ME
THIS TIME --
SO.
I KNOW NOT.
BUT I PLEDGE TO DEFEND THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM.
AND TODAY I WANT TO TALK TO YOU
ABOUT HOW WE CAN DO THAT
TOGETHER.
LOOK BY EVERY TRADITIONAL
MEASURE YOU JUST HEARD THAT THE
STATE OF OUR STATE IS STRONG.
WE HAVE THAT RECORD BREAKING
SURPLUS WE'VE ADDED OVER THREE
MILLION JOBS SINCE THE DEATH OF
THE RECESSION WE'RE SEEING WAGES
RISING.
WHEN A STATE WITH MORE
SCIENTISTS MORE ENGINEERS MORE
NOBEL LAUREATES MORE VENTURE
CAPITAL MORE PATENTS EMANATING
THAN ANY OTHER PART?
OF THIS COUNTRY AND WE OF COURSE
HAVE THE FINEST.
SYSTEM OF HIGHER EDUCATION
ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD.
BUT A ALONG WITH THAT PROSPERITY
AND PROGRESS THERE ARE PROBLEMS
THAT HAVE BEEN DEFERRED TOO LONG.
AND THAT TRIED TO PUT THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM OUT OF REACH
FOR TOO MANY.
BUT WE FACE HARD DECISIONS THAT
ARE COMING DUE.
AND THE CHOICES WE MAKE WILL
SHAPE OUR FUTURE AND THE FUTURE
QUITE LITERALLY MILLIONS FOR
DECADES TO COME AND THIS IS WHAT
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT TODAY AS
FRANKLY.
AND IS DIRECTLY AS I CAN THE
TOUGH CALLS WE MUST MAKE
TOGETHER.
ISSUES LIKE RAIL ON WATER.
AND ENERGY.
HOW WE PROTECT OUR MIGRANTS HOW
WE CARE FOR OUR SENIORS HOW WE
HELP ARE HOMELESS?
AND HOW ABOVE ALL ELSE WE TACKLE
I SAYS THAT IS COMING TO THE
FIND LIFE IN THE STATE.
I WON'T PRETEND TO HAVE ALL THE
ANSWERS BUT THE ONLY WAY TO FIND
THEM IS.
TO I THINK FACE THESE ISSUES
HONEST [inaudible]
LET'S START.
LET'S START WITH SOME OF THE
FEAR MONGERING.
THAT'S COMING OUT OF THE WHITE
HOUSE ABOUT THIS.
QUOTE UNQUOTE SO CALLED BORDER
EMERGENCY --
FOR ME. FOR ME THIS IS AN ECHO
FROM FIFTEEN YEARS AGO I WAS IN
A NEW MAYOR.
SITTING IN THE GALLERY AT THE
STATE OF THE UNION.
AND WASHING WHEN PRESIDENT BUSH
SAID THAT THE LGBT AMERICANS
COULD NOT BE ABLE TO GET MARRIED.
WAS AN ATTACK FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE ON OUR FRIENDS OUR
NEIGHBORS AND ON CALIFORNIA
VALUES.
I WAS SO PROUD TO WATCH BRAVE
CALIFORNIANS ANSWER THOSE
ATTACKS WITH LOVE AND COURAGE.
PHYLLIS LINE IN DEL MARTIN MADE
HISTORY WHEN THEY GOT MARRIED
FIFTEEN YEARS AGO TO THIS VERY
DAY.
SO NOW JUST LIKE BACK THEN.
WE MUST STAND UP FOR THOSE THAT
ARE MALIGN.
MARGINALIZED AND SCAPEGOAT.
BECAUSE LAST WEEK.
WE HEARD ANOTHER PRESIDENT STAND
UP OF THE STATE OF THE UNION AN
OFFER A VISION OF AMERICA
FUNDAMENTALLY.
AT ODDS WITH CALIFORNIA VALUES.
IT DESCRIBES A COUNTRY WHERE
INEQUALITY DIDN'T SEEM TO BE A
PROBLEM.
WORK CLIMATE CHANGE THEN EXIST.
AND WHERE THE GREATEST THREAT WE
FACE COMES FROM SEEKING ASYLUM
AT THE BORDER.
IT JUST LAST NIGHT DOWN IN EL
PASO.
HE SAID IT ALL AGAIN.
SO LET'S JUST STATE THE FACTS WE
ARE CURRENTLY EXPERIENCING THE
LOWEST NUMBER OF BORDER CROSSING
SINCE NINETEEN HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY ONE CALIFORNIA LIKE OUR
NATION ARE UNDOCUMENTED
POPULATION IS AT THE LOWEST
LEVEL.
IN MORE THAN A DECADE.
SOME FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND FEWER IN OUR STATE
ALONE.
IMMIGRANTS BOTH HERE LEGALLY.
AND THOSE WITHOUT DOCUMENTATION
COMMIT CRIMES AT A LOWER RATE
THAN NATIVE BORN CITIZENS.
AND THOSE FAMILIES.
IN THOSE FAMILIES THOSE WOMEN
AND CHILDREN SEEKING ASYLUM AT
THE BORDERS ARE DOING SO LEGAL.
THOSE ARE THE FACTS THIS BORDER
EMERGENCY IS NOTHING MORE THAN A
MANUFACTURED CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA WILL NOT BE PART OF
THIS POLITICAL THEATER
.
JUST YESTERDAY I I I SENT A NEW
DIRECTOR OF THE NATIONAL GUARD.
PUT THEM ON A NEW MISSION ONE
THAT'S GONNA FOCUS ON
RESPECTFULLY THE REAL THREATS
FACING OUR STATE.
AND NOW DIRECTOR THE NATIONAL
GUARD THIRD OF THE FORCES THAT
ARE CURRENTLY THE BORDER TO BE
REDEPLOYED TO HELP PREPARE FOR
THE UPCOMING FIRE SEASON BY
JOINING CAL FIRE AND PREVENTION.
AND SUPPRESSION WORK WORK BY
RIGHT BY THE WAY.
IRONICALLY THAT WAS CURTAILED
DURING THE RECENT SUTTER.
ANOTHER THIRD.
WILL BOOST THE NATIONAL GUARD
STATEWIDE COUNTER DRUG TASK
FORCE BY REDEPLOYING UP NORTH TO
GO AFTER ALL THESE ILLEGAL
CANNABIS FARMS MANY OF WHICH ARE
RUN BY THE CARTELS.
THAT ARE DEVASTATING ARE
PRISTINE FORESTS AND
INCREASINGLY THEMSELVES BECOMING
FIRE HAZARDS.
AND THE REMAINING THIRD OF OUR
GUARD.
WE DIRECTED TO TO FOCUS ON
STOPPING SMUGGLING DRUGS AND
GUNS THROUGH EXISTING BORDER
CHECKPOINTS.
THE WALL THAT STRETCHES
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF MILES
THROUGH WILDERNESS WILL DO
NOTHING TO STOP THIS STRUCK THIS
THREAT.
SO THE ANSWER THE WHITE HOUSE
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT.
NO MORE DIVISION NO MORE XENA
PHOBIA.
NO MORE NATIVISM WE SUFFERED
ENOUGH OF THAT IN THE NINETEEN
NINETIES WITH PROPOSITION ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN AND PROPOSITION
[inaudible]
TWO NEXT A LET'S LET LET'S --
AS LEVEL ABOUT THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL.
YOU HAVE NOTHING BUT RESPECT FOR
GOVERNOR BROWN AND GOVERNOR
SCHWARZENEGGER'S.
VISION I SHARE THERE'S NO DOUBT
THAT OUR STATE'S ECONOMY AND
QUALITY OF LIFE DEPEND ON
IMPROVING TRANSPORTATION.
BUT LET'S BE REAL.
PROJECT AS PLANNED WOULD COST
TOO MUCH.
RESPECTFULLY TAKE TOO LONG.
THERE'S BEEN TOO LITTLE
OVERSIGHT.
AND NOT ENOUGH TRANSPARENCY.
RIGHT NOW THERE SIMPLY ISN'T A
PATH TO GET FROM SACRAMENTO TO
SAN DIEGO LET ALONE FROM.
SAN FRANCISCO TO LA.
I WISH THERE WERE [inaudible]
HOWEVER [inaudible]
HE WE DO HAVE THE CAPACITY TO
COMPLETE A HIGH SPEED RAIL LINK
BETWEEN MERCED AND BAKERSFIELD
NOW I KNOW.
I KNOW SOME CRITICS ARE GONNA
SAY WELL THAT'S A TRAINED IN A
WAY.
BUT I THINK THAT'S WRONG.
AND I THINK THAT'S OFFENSIVE.
THE PEOPLE OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY
IN DURING THE WORST AIR
POLLUTION IN AMERICA AND HAVE
SOME OF THE LONGEST COMMUTES IN
THIS STATE.
AND THEY HAVE SUFFERED TOO MANY
YEARS OF NEGLECT FROM POLICY
MAKERS RESPECTFULLY HERE IN
SACRAMENTO.
THEY DESERVE BETTER.
AND A HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT TO
BE PART OF YOU CAN SEE THERE'S
ANOTHER HIGH SPEED RAIL IS MORE
THAN A TRAIN PROJECT.
IT'S ABOUT ECONOMIC
TRANSFORMATION IT'S ABOUT
UNLOCKING THE ENORMOUS POTENTIAL
OF THE VALLEY.
NO WE CAN ALIGN OUR ECONOMIC AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT STRATEGIES
ANCHORED BY THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
IN TO THEM WITH TOOLS LIKE
OPPORTUNITIES ONS THAT COULD
FORM THE BACKBONE OF THE RE
INVIGORATED.
CENTRAL VALLEY ECONOMY.
MERCED FRESNO BAKERSFIELD AND
COMMUNITIES IN BETWEEN ARE MORE
DYNAMIC THAN PEOPLE REALIZE
[inaudible]
THE VALLEY.
WELL.
THE VALLEY MAY BE KNOWN AROUND
THE WORLD [inaudible] FOR
AGRICULTURE.
BUT THERE'S ANOTHER STORY.
READY TO BE TOLD A STORY OF A
REGION HUNGRY FOR INVESTMENT A
WORK FORCE EAGER FOR MORE
TRAINING AND GOOD JOBS
CALIFORNIANS THAT DESERVE A FAIR
SHARE OF OUR STATES PROSPERITY.
LOOK.
WILL CONTINUE. TO SUPPORT OUR
REGIONAL PROJECTS NORTH AND
SOUTH.
WE'LL FINISH PHASE ONE OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORK.
WILL CONNECT THE REVITALIZED
CENTRAL VALLEY TO OTHER PARTS OF
THE STATE AND WE WILL CONTINUE
TO PUSH FOR FOR MORE FEDERAL
FUNDING AND PRIVATE DOLLARS.
BUT LET'S GET SOMETHING DONE
ONCE AND FOR ALL.
AND FOR THOSE OF YOU.
I KNOW YOU'RE OUT THERE THAT
THAT JUST WANT TO THROW AWAY
THIS.
WHOLE PROJECT.
SO TO GIVE UP ON THIS ALL IN
THIS OFFER YOU THIS.
ABANDONING THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
ENTIRELY MEANS WE WILL HAVE
WASTED BILLIONS AND BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS WITH NOTHING BUT BROKEN
PROMISES PARTIALLY.
FILLED COMMITMENTS AND LAWSUITS
TO SHOW FOR AND WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT.
I HAVE NO INTEREST IN SENDING
BACK THREE AND A HALF BILLION
DOLLARS OF FEDERAL FUNDING THAT
WAS ALLOCATED TO THIS PROJECT TO
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP.
THAT WOULD DO IT AT THAT
FUNDAMENTALLY WOULD HAVE TO
HAPPEN.
BUT WE JUST WALKED AWAY.
BUT ALSO I'M NOT INTERESTED IN
MAKING THE SAME ALL MISTAKES AND
THAT'S WHY TODAY I'M ORDERING
SOME NEW TRANSPARENCY MEASURES.
GONNA HOLD CONTRACTORS.
GONNA WHOLE CONSULTANTS
ACCOUNTABLE HAVING TO EXPLAIN
HOW TAX DOLLARS ARE SPENT
INCLUDING CHANGE ORDERS COST
OVER RUNS AND EVEN TRAVEL
EXPENSES
.
WE'RE ALSO WERE ALSO GOING TO
SEIZE OF GOVERNANCE CHANGES
STARTING WITH MY MY PICK FOR THE
NEXT CHAIR OF THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL AUTHORITY LENNY MEN DOGS UP
MY ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT DIRECTOR.
ONE IS YOU KNOW IS IS RUNNING
ECONOMIC A WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AND I THIS FUNDAMENTALLY BELIEVE
THAT.
TRANSPORTATION AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT GO HAND IN HAND SO.
THAT'S A POSITION OUR HIGH SPEED
RIGHT.
LET'S TALK ABOUT WATER.
WE NEED A FRESH APPROACH WHEN IT
COMES TO MEETING CALIFORNIA'S
MASSIVE WATER CHALLENGES.
WITH A BIG STATE DIVERSE WATER
NEEDS CITIES IN THAT THAT NEED
CLEAN DRINKING WATER.
FARMS IN THE IRRIGATION TO KEEP
FEEDING THE WORLD FRAGILE
ECOSYSTEMS THAT MUST BE
PROTECTED.
OUR WATER SUPPLIES BECOMING LESS
RELIABLE BECAUSE OF CLIMATE
CHANGE IN OUR POPULATIONS
GROWING.
BECAUSE A STRONG ECONOMY.
THAT MEANS A LOT OF DEMAND ON
UNPREDICTABLE SUPPLY.
THERE ARE NO EASY ANSWERS BUT
LET ME BE AS DIRECT ABOUT WHERE
I STAND AS I CAN'T.
I DO NOT SUPPORT THE WATER FIX
AS CURRENTLY CONFIGURED.
MEETING I DO NOT SUPPORT THE
TWIN TOWERS.
WE CAN HOWEVER BUILD ON THE
IMPORTANT WORK THAT'S ALREADY
BEEN DONE.
AND THAT'S WHY I DO SUPPORT.
A C. THE STATUS QUO IS NOT AN
OPTION.
WE NEED TO PROTECT OUR WATER
SUPPLY FROM EARTHQUAKES FROM
RISING SEA LEVELS WE NEED TO
PRESERVE DELTA FISHERIES AND WE
NEED TO MEET THE NEEDS OF CITIES
AND FARMS.
WE HAVE GOT TO GET PAST IS ALL
BINARIES LIKE FARMERS VERSUS
ENVIRONMENTALISTS THE NORTH
VERSUS SOUTH.
OUR APPROACH CAN'T BE EITHER OR
IT HAS TO BE YES AND CONVEYANCE
AND EFFICIENCY.
AND RECYCLING PROJECTS LIKE THE
ONES WERE SEEN IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA MET WATER DISTRICT.
EXPANDING FLOOD PLAINS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY GROUNDWATER
RECHARGE LIKE FARMERS ARE
ALREADY DOING IN FRESNO COUNTY.
A PORTFOLIO APPROACH TO THE
BUILDING WATER INFRASTRUCTURE IN
MEETING LONG TERM DEMAND.
IN TO HELP BRING THIS BALANCE.
I'M APPOINTING A NEW CHAIR TO
THE CALIFORNIA WATER BOARD LOS
JOAQUIN ESCADA.
IN HIS FIRST TASK.
HIS FIRST TASK OUR COLLECTIVE
EFFORT MUST BE TO CROSS THE
FINISH LINE ON REAL AGREEMENTS
TO SAVE THE SAT SACRAMENTO.
SAN JOAQUIN BAY DELTA.
WE MUST GET THIS DONE FOR THE
RESILIENCE OF A MIGHTY RIVERS.
FOR THE STABILITY OF OUR
AGRICULTURAL SECTOR IN THE
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF PEOPLE.
THAT DEPEND ON THIS WATER
EVERYDAY.
NOW LET'S TALK HONESTLY ABOUT
CLEAN DRINKING WATER.
AND THIS IS NOT ME TAKING A SIP
AS A PROP --
BUT JUST THIS MORNING.
JUST THIS MORNING MORE THAN A
MILLION CALIFORNIANS WOKE UP
WITHOUT CLEAN WATER BASIN LET
ALONE DRINK.
SOME SCHOOLS HAVE SHUT DOWN
DRINKING FOUNTAINS DUE TO
CONTAMINATION.
SOME POOR COMMUNITIES LIKE THOSE
I RECENTLY VISITED IN STANISLAUS
COUNTY ARE PAYING MORE FOR ON
DRINKABLE WATER.
THEN BEVERLY HILLS PAYS FOR PER
ST THIS.
PRISTINE WATER.
WITH RESPECT THIS IS A MORAL
DISGRACE AND IT'S A MEDICAL
EMERGENCY.
THERE ARE LITERALLY HUNDREDS OF
WATER SYSTEMS ACROSS THIS STATE
CONTAMINATED BY LEAD.
CONTAMINATED BY ARSENIC AND YOUR
RANGE.
IN SOLVING THIS CRISIS IT WILL
DEMAND SUSTAINED FUNDING BUT
MORE.
NOTHING ELSE IT'S GONNA DEMAND
POLITICAL WILL FROM EACH AND
EVERYONE OF US [inaudible]
LET'S.
LET'S TALK ABOUT OUR ENERGY
FUTURE.
AND THE P. GINNY BANKRUPTCY.
WE'RE ALL FRUSTRATED OR ANGRY
IT'S HAD TO COME TO THIS BG DID
NOT DO ENOUGH TO SECURE DATERS
APPOINTMENT OR PLAN FOR THE
FUTURE.
MY ADMINISTRATION WILL WORK TO
MAKE SURE P. GINNY UP HOLD ITS
OBLIGATIONS.
A CONVENE THE TEAM OF THE
NATION'S BEST BANKRUPTCY
ATTORNEYS AND AND FINANCIAL
EXPERTS FROM ACROSS THE ENERGY
SECTOR.
THEY WILL WORK WITH MY STRIKE
TEAM TO DEVELOP A COMPREHENSIVE
STRATEGY THAT WE WILL PRESENT
WITHIN SIXTY DAYS.
WE WILL ENSURE CONTINUED ACCESS
TO SAFE AFFORDABLE POWER.
WE WILL SEEK JUSTICE FOR FIRE
VICTIMS FAIRNESS FOR EMPLOYEES
AND PROTECTION FOR RATEPAYERS.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO INVEST IN
SAFETY AND WE WILL NEVER WAVER
ON ACHIEVING THE NATION'S MOST
AMBITIOUS CLEAN ENERGY GOALS.
BUT THE PROBLEMS WE FACE ARE FAR
GREATER.
THAN TEACHING.
CLIMATE CHANGE IS PUTTING
PRESSURE ON ALL OF OUR UTILITIES
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE NORTH AND
SOUTH.
EDISON AND SAN DIEGO GAS AND
ELECTRIC MOST RECENTLY HAD THEIR
CREDIT RATINGS DOWN WITH.
THIS PRESSURE COMES AT A TIME
WHEN THE ENTIRE ENERGY MARKET IS
EVOLVING FROM ROOFTOP SOLAR WIND
GENERATION TO SMART GRID
TECHNOLOGIES FROM COMMUNITY
CHOICE AGGREGATORS TO DIRECT
ACCESS SERVICE.
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS POWER
PURCHASE AGREEMENTS ELECTRICITY
NOW IS BEING PROCURED OUTSIDE OF
THE INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES.
REGULATIONS AND INSURANCE
PRACTICES THAT WERE CREATED
DECADES AGO THEY DID NOT
ANTICIPATE THESE CHANGES.
SO WE MUST MAP OUT A LONGER TERM
FRAMEWORK NOT JUST FOR THE
UTILITIES FUTURE BUT FOR
CALIFORNIA'S ENERGY FUTURE. TO
ENSURE THAT THE COSTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE DOESN'T FALL ON THOSE
LEAST ABLE TO AFFORD.
I WANT -- TO
BRIEFLY EDUCATION.
THE TEACHER STRIKE IN LA IS OVER
ABOUT THE NEED TO CONFRONT A
TYLER UNDERLYING CAUSES
OBVIOUSLY IS ONLY JUST BEGUN.
UNDERSTAFFED SCHOOLS OVER
CROWDED CLASSROOMS PENSION
PRESSURES THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP
GROWTH OF CHARTER SCHOOLS THE
STRESSORS ARE SHOWING UP ALL
OVER THE STATE.
RIGHT HERE IN SACRAMENTO IN
FRESNO IN OAKLAND.
DISTRICTS ACROSS THE STATE --
OUR CHALLENGE TO BALANCE BUDGETS
EVEN IN THIS STRONG ECONOMY.
THE TIME WE'RE SPENDING MORE ON
SCHOOLS THAN WE HAVE EVER BEFORE.
SEVEN YEARS AGO WE INVESTED
FORTY SEVEN POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS IN OUR SCHOOLS NEXT YEAR
WITH YOUR SUPPORT.
WILL INVEST OVER EIGHTY MILLION
DOLLARS BY THE WAY THAT IT COULD
FIVE HUNDRED SEVENTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION.
BUT IT'S NOT ENOUGH.
WE'RE STILL FORTY FIRST IN THE
NATION.
IN PER PUPIL FUNDING.
SOMETHING NEEDS TO CHANGE.
IT'S LONG OVERDUE THAT WE HAVE
THAT HONEST CONVERSATION ABOUT
HOW WE FUND OUR SCHOOLS NOT ONLY
AT THE STATE LEVEL.
BUT THE LOCAL.
AT THE SAME TIME THOUGH LET'S
REMEMBER THAT THE MEASURE OF THE
SCHOOL SYSTEMS EXCELLENCE IS
MORE THAN THE SUM OF ITS BUDGETS.
WE NEED CLEAR AND ACHIEVABLE
STANDARDS OF TRANSPARENCY.
MORE INFORMATION SHARING IN
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR ALL PUBLIC
SCHOOLS TRADITIONAL AND CHARTER
SCHOOL.
WE ALSO NEED A NEW PRESIDENT FOR
THE STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION TO
WORK WITH OUR SUPERINTENDENT.
TONY THURMOND.
WELCOME STUDENTS AND MARK THANK.
THAT POSITION IS NATIONALLY
RECOGNIZED EXPERT LINDA DARLING
HAMMOND [inaudible]
THANK.
THERE'S ANOTHER.
URGENT MORAL ISSUE.
WE MUST CONFRONT.
THAT'S THIS HOMELESSNESS
HOMELESSNESS.
EPIDEMIC.
SO MANY OF CALIFORNIA'S ALMOST
WHETHER THEIR THEIR FAMILIES
VETERANS VICTIMS OF RENT SPIKES
OR SURVIVORS PLANE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE ARE INVISIBLE AND LEFT
BEHIND BY OUR SOCIETY. TOO MANY
ON THE STREETS ARE SUFFERING
FROM BIPOLAR DISORDER
SCHIZOPHRENIA PARANOIA MANY OF
THEM SELF MEDICATING WITH DRUGS
OR ALCOHOL ADDICTION.
IS A CONSEQUENCE ARE HOMELESS
CRISIS IS INCREASINGLY BECOMING
A PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS.
LAST YEAR WE HAD HEPATITIS A
OUTBREAK IN SAN DIEGO RECENTLY
THERE'S AN OUTBREAK A SURPLUS.
UP IN SO NO MY TYPE BASE.
IN LOS ANGELES.
TYPE X.. EIGHT MADE EVIL DISEASE
AND CALIFORNIA IN TWO THOUSAND
AND NINETY I KNOW MAYOR IS I
KNOW COUNTY SUPERVISOR CITY
COUNCIL ALL AROUND THE STATE ARE
WORKING HARD.
TO REDUCE HOMELESSNESS AND ITS
UNDERLYING CAUSES BUT WE'VE GOT
TO HAVE THEIR BACKS THEY CANNOT
DO IT ALONE.
STANDING UP AT THE IN.
WE DID DISCUSS INSTANCE KEEPS
STANDING UP THERE ARE --
APPOINTING THERE ARE STEINBERG
TO A NEW COMMISSION ON
HOMELESSNESS IN SUPPORT OF
HOUSING THANK YOU MAYOR SCOTT
.
WITH YOUR SUPPORT.
WE'RE GONNA PUT UP.
ANOTHER HALF A BILLION DOLLARS
INTO IMMEDIATE FUNDING FOR
NAVIGATION CENTERS MERCY
SHELTERS WITH SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES ON SITE.
WITH THIS BOOK ABOUT ANOTHER
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS AND THE
WHOLE THREE HOUSING.
MENTAL HEALTH AND MORE PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING BECAUSE AT
THE END OF THE DAY SHELTER SOL
SLEEP HOUSING AND SUPPORT
SERVICES SOLVED HOMELESS
.
TALK ABOUT SOMETHING.
WE TOO OFTEN OVERLOOK.
THE GOLDEN STATE IS GETTING
GRAYER.
WE NEED TO GET READY FOR THIS
MAJOR DEMOGRAPHIC CHALLENGE
HEADED OUR WAY. FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN OUR HISTORY OLDER
CALIFORNIANS WHAT OUR NUMBER
YOUNG CHILDREN.
OVER THE NEXT DECADE OR
STATEWIDE SENIOR POPULATION IS
PROJECTED TO INCREASE BY FOUR
MILLION.
IN TWENTY FIVE YEARS IT'S GOING
TO DOUBLE.
IN MORE THAN HALF WILL REQUIRE
SOME FORM OF LONG TERM CARE.
GOING ALL THOSE NO BOUNDARIES
AGING DOESN'T CARE WHAT RACE YOU
ARE YOUR ECONOMIC STATUS WHETHER
YOU'RE SINGLE.
OR YOU HAVE FAMILY SUPPORT.
AND I HAVE SOME PERSONAL.
AND PAINFUL EXPERIENCE WITH THIS
RECENTLY I I LOST MY FATHER SOME
YOU KNOW OVER THE HOLIDAYS AFTER
YEARS AND YEARS OF DECLINING
PHYSICAL HEALTH.
AND DIMENSION.
YOU WAS THE TERMINAL LIVE OUT
HIS DAYS WITH DIGNITY.
YOU ALSO HAVE TO BE RETIRED
PUBLIC OFFICIAL WITH OF A GOOD
PENSION.
AND A SUPPORT CIRCLE OF FAMILY
AND FRIENDS BUT EVEN WITH ALL OF
THOSE ADVANTAGE.
ALL OF THOSE ADVANTAGES.
WITH THE DAILY CHALLENGE FOR HIM
TO MEET HIS NEEDS SO HE CAN LIVE
IN PLACE AND MAINTAIN.
A GOOD QUALITY OF LIFE.
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIAN SHERRY
SIMILAR STORY AND THE NUMBERS.
ARE THE ONLY GROW.
IT'S TIME FOR A NEW MASTER PLAN
ON AGING IN CALIFORNIA
.
YOU KNOW IT'S GOT --
DRESS PERSON CENTERED CARE.
THE PATCHWORK OF PUBLIC SERVICES.
GOT ADDRESS SOCIAL ISOLATION.
BETTER LOCK SENIORS THE NEED
TRANSPORTATION.
DRESS THE NURSING SHORTAGE LV
ENDS IN OUR ENDS.
AND THE DEMAND ON AYE HSS ARNOLD
SUPPORT SERVICES THAT FAR
OUTPACES ITS CAPACITY.
AND YOU KNOW WE CAN'T TALK ABOUT.
AGING WITHOUT ALSO FOCUSING ON
ALL TIMES. TOO MANY OF US IN THE
CRUSHING GRIP OF THIS DISEASE ON
OUR LOVED ONES ESPECIALLY ON OUR
WIVES AND MOTHERS.
BECAUSE TWO THIRDS OF ALL NEW
ALZHEIMER'S CASES ARE WOMEN. TWO
THIRDS.
SO TODAY I'M WATCHING THE ALL
TIMES PREVENTION AND
PREPAREDNESS TASK FORCE BRING IN
THE MOST RENOWNED SCIENTIST AND
THINKERS TOGETHER TO DEVELOP THE
FIRST OF ITS KIND RESEARCH IN
THIS AREA.
IT WILL BE HEADED.
BY LEADING ADVOCATE FOR FAMILIES
DEALING WITH ALZHEIMER'S.
AND THAT IS OUR FORMER EIGHTY
MARIA SHRIVER [inaudible]
AND WE'RE UHHUH
[inaudible]
DIE TOGETHER.
MANY OF THESE ARE CHALLENGES WE
FACE IS THE BROADER COST.
CRISIS.
IN A RECENT SURVEY CAME OUT LAST
WEEK 61% OF YOUNG ADULTS IN
CALIFORNIA SO THEY CAN'T AFFORD
TO LIVE. 61%.
CALIFORNIA SHOULD NEVER BE A
PLACE WHERE ONLY THE WELL OFF
CAN LEAD A GOOD LIFE.
AND IT STARTS WITH HOUSING
PERHAPS THE MOST OVERWHELMING
CHALLENGE WE FACE RIGHT NOW.
WE ALL KNOW THE PROBLEM.
WELL THE PROBLEM. TOO MUCH
DEMAND. TOO LITTLE SUPPORT.
AND THAT IS HAPPENING IN LARGE
PART BECAUSE TOO MANY CITIES AND
COUNTIES AREN'T EVEN PLANNING
HOW TO BUILD.
SUMMER FLAT OUT REFUSING TO DO
ANYTHING AT ALL.
THAT'S WHY I COMMITTED SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR A MAJOR NEW
INCENTIVE PACKAGE FOR
COMMUNITIES TO DO THE RIGHT
THING. TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN SUPPORT FOR CITIES
AND COUNTIES TO UPDATE THEIR
HOUSING PLANS TO REVAMP THERE'S
ONLY PROCESS AND GET MORE
HOUSING ENTITLED. FIVE HUNDRED
MORE IN GRANTS WHEN THEY ACHIEVE
CERTAIN MILESTONES.
PUT IT WE WANT A CALIFORNIA FOR
ALL WE HAVE TO BUILD HOUSING FOR
ALL
.
I WANT TO SUPPORT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
GOVERNMENTS TO DO WHAT'S RIGHT.
LIKE ANAHEIM.
LIKE SANTA ROSA.
BUT THERE'S GOTTA BE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THOSE THAT DO
NOT.
CAN ALL TWO WEEKS AGO.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SUED THE
CITY OF HUNTINGTON BEACH FOR
FAILING TO MEET.
ITS OBLIGATIONS ON AFFORDABLE
HOUSING LET ME JUST TELL YOU
LOOK AT THE FORMER MAYOR THE
LAST THING I WANT TO DO IS THE
START MY TERM.
SUING THE CITY.
BUT RESPECTFULLY THEY LEFT US NO
CHOICE.
BY THE WAY IT'S NOT BOB PICKING
ON HUNTINGTON BEACH THEY JUST
HAPPEN TO BE FIRST BECAUSE OF A
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS.
BUT THERE ARE FORTY SEVEN OTHER
CITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA THAT
ARE NOT COMPLYING WITH THEIR
PLANNING REQUIREMENTS IN ONE WAY
OR ANOTHER.
SOME CITIES ARE TRYING LIKE
CLOTHES.
BUT OTHERS RESPECTFULLY.
LIKE WE WENT.
HUNTINGTON PARK MONTEBELLO
THEY'RE NOT.
SOME INVITING ALL THE CITY
LEADERS TO SIT DOWN WITH ME IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA NEXT WEEK
FOR A CANDID CONVERSATION.
I DO NOT INTEND TO FILE SUIT
AGAINST ALL FORTY SEVEN BUT I'M
NOT GOING TO PRESIDE OVER
NEGLECT AND DENIAL ANY LONGER
.
I WAS A LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIAL I
I'M NOT NAIVE.
THAT CITIES NEED TO SOME OF THAT
POLITICAL COURAGE AND WE GONNA
HAVE THEIR BACKS.
OKAY I ALSO WANTING KNOWLEDGE.
THAT THERE ARE OTHER FACTORS
BEYOND CITY PLANNING THAT HAVE
LIMITED OUR ABILITY TO PROVIDE
MORE HOUSES.
IN RECENT YEARS YOU KNOW.
WE'VE DONE A GOOD JOB EXPEDITING
JUDICIAL REVIEW ON SEA QUEST FOR
PROFESSIONAL SPORTS
.
THERE'S SOME GOOD THINGS
HAPPENING.
SOMEONE APPLAUD.
THE RECENT EFFORTS BY HOME
BUILDERS AND LABOR LEADERS WHO
TOGETHER WORKING TO FORGE A
COMPROMISE IN THE SPACE TO
ACCELERATE PRODUCTION.
BUT THERE'S NO WAY WE CAN
ACHIEVE OUR AMBITIOUS TARGETS
UNLESS WE TRAIN A SKILLED
WORKFORCE.
THAT'S BIG ENOUGH TO MEET THE
CHALLENGE AND ALSO.
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE WORKERS
THAT ARE GETTING WAGES THAT ARE
HIGH ENOUGH TO ALSO SUPPORT
THEIR FAMILIES.
PLEASE.
AT THE PURCHASE PROCESS AND AND
LET'S BRING MORE PEOPLE TO THE
TABLE TO GET SOMETHING BIG DONE
I AM CONFIDENT WE CAN DO THAT
THIS YEAR.
AND WHILE WE'RE AT IT.
LET'S NOT FORGET ABOUT SOMETHING
ELSE.
A LOT OF US MADE COMMITMENTS
MYSELF INCLUDED.
AFTER PROPOSITION TEN FAILED AT
THE BALLOT LAST NOVEMBER.
AND THE PRESSURE ON VULNERABLE
RENTERS DID NOT GO AWAY.
AFTER ELECTION.
WE NEED NEW RULES TO STABILIZE
NEIGHBORHOODS TO PREVENT THE
VACATIONS WITHOUT PUTTING SMALL
LANDLORDS OUT OF BUSINESS.
SO I WANT THE BEST IDEA FROM
EVERYONE IN THIS CHAMBER AND
HERE'S MY PROMISE TO YOU.
GET ME A GOOD PACKAGE ON RENT
STABILITY THIS YEAR AND I WILL
SIGN
.
WE'RE SERIOUS ABOUT OBTAINING
THE COST CRISIS.
WE ALSO NEED TO BE SERIOUS ABOUT.
MAKING SURE HEALTHCARE IS A FOR
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
AND OUR ABILITY ABILITY TO
INVEST.
IT EVERYTHING WE CARE ABOUT IS
CONSTRAINED BY THIS ISSUE BY THE
GROWING PRESSURE.
HAS BEEN FOR YEARS ARE
DESTROYING THE AFFORDABLE CARE
ACT.
THEIR VANDALISM BY THE WAY IS
ALREADY DONE.
EXTRAORDINARY DAMAGE IN
CALIFORNIA BY ELIMINATING THE
INDIVIDUAL MANDATE.
THIS YEAR COVERED CALIFORNIA'S
PREMIUMS INCREASED ALMOST TWICE
AS MUCH.
AS WE HAD EXPECTED.
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT WE FEAR AND
RESPECT LIKE IT'S EXACTLY WHAT
THEY WANT.
AND THAT'S WHY WHEN IT COMES TO
THE INDIVIDUAL MANDATE
CALIFORNIA MUST ACT WHERE
WASHINGTON HAS FAILED.
WE DO THIS WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE
TO DEEPEN SUBSIDIES FOR THOSE
EARNING UP TO FORTY EIGHT
THOUSAND DOLLARS AN EXTENDED
SUBSIDIES TO FAMILIES.
EARNING UP TO ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS SOMETHING
NO OTHER STATE IN AMERICA HAS
DONE.
WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO THAT.
ON ANOTHER ISSUE.
WE ALL KNOW THAT.
CALIFORNIA HAS AMONG THE LOWEST
MEDICAID REIMBURSEMENT RATES IN
AMERICA.
AND THAT'S WHY IN OUR BUDGET WE
DEVOTE MORE THAN ONE BILLION
DOLLARS TO INCREASE RATES AND
ADDRESS THE GROWING PROVIDERS
SHORTAGE.
THIS THIS INVESTMENT WILL ALLOW
IS TO INCREASE ACCESS TO
PREVENTIVE HEALTH MEASURES LIKE
IMMUNIZATIONS PROMISE SCREENINGS
AND MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AS
WELL AS PROVIDE ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. FOR
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH AND FAMILY
PLANNING
.
WHAT WE PURSUE THE LONG TERM
GOAL SINGLE PAYER FINANCING LET
US MAKE A DOWN PAYMENT NOW?
LIKE SPENDING MEDI CAL COVERAGE
FOR CALIFORNIANS UP TO THE AGE
OF TWENTY SIX REGARDLESS OF
THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS
.
THIS IS ONLY PART OF THE
SOLUTION.
COSTS IS ANOTHER.
WE MUST ADDRESS RISING COSTS
THROUGHOUT THE SYSTEM.
LIKE THE CONSOLIDATION OF
HOSPITALS AND OTHER HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS WHICH IN MANY CASES
LIMITED PATIENT CHOICE.
THEY MADE MEDICAL CARE SIMPLY
MORE EXPENSIVE
WE ALSO MUST CONTINUE TO BRING
DOWN THE COST OF PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS.
MY MY MY FIRST HALF HIS
GOVERNMENT.
WAS TO LAY THE FOUNDATION FOR
SINGLE PURCHASING SYSTEM THE
LARGEST STATE BUYER IN THE
NATION WHICH BY THE WAY WILL
SAVE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS A YEAR FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND I WANT TO THANK.
AT LEAST SOMEONE CARES ABOUT
THAT SAVINGS BUT I WANT TO THANK
I WANT TO THANK.
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
I WANT TO THANK PRESIDENT SHRUB
FOR CALLING ATTENTION TO
PRESCRIPTION DRUG PRICES LAST
WEEK IN A STATE OF THE UNION.
THIS IS A BI PARTISAN ISSUE AT
LEAST IT SHOULD BE AND I HOPE HE
FOLLOWS THROUGH AND TAKES THE
LEAD OF CALIFORNIA IN THE
PROCESS.
I LET'S TALK ABOUT JOBS
[inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
WE GOT ASK OURSELVES.
HOW DO WE CREATE A FUTURE?
WITH MORE GOOD JOBS AND HIGHER
WAGES.
BECAUSE WHEN IT COMES TO MAKING
LIVE IN CALIFORNIA MORE
AFFORDABLE COST IS ONLY ONE SIDE.
OF THE EQUATION THE OTHERS
INCOME.
SO DESPITE OUR OUR ROOM RISING
WAGES WORKING FAMILIES IN
CALIFORNIA TODAY BARELY EARN
MORE THAN THEY DID A DECADE AGO.
MANY WORKING PARENTS ARE MAKING
LESS THAN THEIR PARENTS DID AT
THE SAME AGE.
THAT'S WHY WITH YOUR SUPPORT.
WE WERE BOOKED RE PROVIDING THIS
YEAR A COST OF LIVING REFUND BY
EXPANDING THE EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT TWO EIGHT MILLION MORE
CALIFORNIA
.
THE BUDGET FOR FAMILIES WITH
KIDS UNDER THE AGE SIX THEY WILL
SEE THEIR BENEFITS GO UP BY AS
MUCH AS THREE TIMES.
LOOK IN THIS ECONOMY
[inaudible]
J. BACK.
LOOK IN THIS ECONOMY WITH THE
WORLD OF WORK IS IN A PERPETUAL
STATE OF FLUX WHERE WORKERS ARE
TOO OFTEN DISPLACED THE VALUE TO
DISCONNECTED FROM THE SOCIAL
SAFETY NET WE ALSO MUST.
THINK BIGGER.
IT'S TIME TO DEVELOP A NEW
MODERN COMPACT FOR CALIFORNIA'S
CHANGING WORKFORCE.
THIS RESPECTFULLY IS MUCH BIGGER
THAN DYNAMAX.
CALIFORNIA NEEDS A COMPREHENSIVE
STATEWIDE STRATEGY UP LIFT AND
UP SKILL OUR WORKERS TO ENSURE
THAT TECHNOLOGICAL ADVANCEMENTS
IN A AYE BLOCKCHAIN BIG DATA ARE
CREATING JOBS NOT DESTROYING
JOBS.
I BELIEVE WE NEED TO REFORM.
OUR INSTITUTIONS THAT SO THE
MORE WORKERS HAVE AN OWNERSHIP
STAKE.
IN THEIR SWEAT EQUITY.
SO WILL APPOINT A NEW COMMISSION
I CALIFORNIA'S WORKFORCE AND
FUTURE OF WORK THAT WILL BRING
TOGETHER LEADERS FROM LABOR
BUSINESS WILL PUBLIC.
AND PRIVATE IN THEIR SIMON IS
THIS TO COME UP WITH NEW IDEAS
TO EXPAND WORKER OPPORTUNITY
WITHOUT EXTINGUISHING INNOVATION
OF FLEXIBILITY.
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA'S OBVIOUSLY
PROUD. TO BE HOME TECHNOLOGY
COMPANIES THAT ARE DETERMINED TO
CHANGE THE WORLD THE COMPANIES
THAT MAKE RESPECTFULLY BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS COLLECTING.
CURATING MONETIZING OUR PERSONAL
DATA ALSO HAVE A DUTY TO PROTECT.
CONSUMERS HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW
AND CONTROL HOW THEIR DATA IS
BEING USED THANK YOU FOR PASSING
THE FIRST IN THE NATION DIGITAL
PRIVACY LAW LAST YEAR
[inaudible]
WELL.
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS SHOULD ALSO
BE ABLE TO SHARE IN THE WEALTH.
THAT IS CREATED FROM THEIR DATA
SO I ASKED MY TEAM TO DEVELOP A
PROPOSAL FOR A NEW DATA DIVIDEND
FOR CALIFORNIA.
RE RECORD. TO YOU WE CAN DO
SOMETHING BOLD IN THE SPACE.
LET ME AND BY MAKING THE OBVIOUS
POINT WOULD COVER A LOT OF BROWN.
BUT THERE'S A LOT MORE THAT
DESERVES OUR FOCUS CLIMATE
CHANGE REFORM IN OUR TAX CODE.
OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
MAJOR NATIONS LIKE PAID SICK
LEAVE UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL FREE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE REIMAGINING
THE DMV.
THERE'S THERE'S SO MUCH MORE IT
WILL BE TAKEN OUT ALL THOSE
ISSUES AND MORE.
IN THE COMING MONTHS.
HI MY NOT ARRIVE.
A FEW WEEKS BACK I QUOTED THE
SERMON ON THE MOUNT.
ABOUT A HOUSE.
I DID NOT CALL THE FACE OF
FLOODS.
AND STORMS BECAUSE IT WAS ABOUT
UPON A ROCK.
A PROMISE THAT TOGETHER WE WILL
BUILD ONE HOUSE FOR ONE
CALIFORNIA.
WE STARTED DRAWING THE BLUEPRINT
FOR THAT HOUSE IN IT TOGETHER.
GONNA FINISHES BUT THIS GOES
DEEPER THAN BUDGET NUMBERS
FRIEDMAN PROGRAM DETAILS THIS IS
ABOUT THE BONDS.
BETWEEN US AS HUMAN BEINGS.
AND I ST PAUL SAID WE ARE MANY
PARTS BUT ONE BODY.
WERE ALL DIMINISHED WHEN ONE OF
THE STRUGGLES THE PROBLEMS WE
FACE ARE AS HARD AS THEY COME IN
THERE IN MANY CASES DECADES IN
THE MAKING.
BUT I TRULY BELIEVE WE HAVE THE
TOOLS TO SOLVE THEM WITH THE
TECHNOLOGY WE HAVE THE KNOW HOW
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY.
WE HAVE THE GENEROSITY OF OUR
PEOPLE.
HOW MANY REMEMBER THE STORY OF
THAT REGISTERED NURSE?
UP IN PARADISE.
WHO IS SITTING IN TRAFFIC?
TRYING TO ESCAPE THE FIRE AS
PLAIN STARTED INVOLVED HIS CAR.
HE THOUGHT THIS IS IT.
ANY RECORDED A GOODBYE VIDEO TO
HIS FAMILY.
THEN A MIRACLE.
A BULLDOZER CAME OUT OF NOWHERE
AND CLEAR THE BURNING CARS ITEMS
PASS.
AT POINT TO GO TO JUST DRIVEN
AWAY AS FAST.
AS POSSIBLE THAT'S WHAT A LOT OF
US WOULD HAVE DONE.
BUT INSTEAD HE TURNED HIS CAR.
AND HE DROVE STRAIGHT TO THE
HOSPITAL IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
TOWN WHERE HE WORKED IN THE I
SEE YOU.
HE IN HIS COLLEAGUES STARTED
TREATING INJURED PEOPLE.
THAN THE HOSPITAL CAUGHT ON FIRE.
HE MOVED PATIENTS TO THE HELIPAD
THAT WAS A HUNDRED YARDS AWAY AS
FAST AS HE COULD.
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THEM WAS
SAFELY EVACUATED.
AND WHEN HE WAS ASKED WHY HE DID
THIS.
WHY DRAW BACK THROUGH THE FIRE
WHEN YOU COULD HAVE JUST SAVED
HIMSELF?
HE SHRUGGED AND SAID.
THIS IS WHAT WE DO.
HIS NAME.
IS ALAN PURSE.
ANY SEVERE WITH US TODAY
[inaudible]
ALLEN'S RIGHT.
TAKING CARE OF EACH OTHER.
SHOWING COURAGE WHEN IT MATTERS
MOST THIS IS WHAT WE DO.
IN CALIFORNIA.
YES WE HAVE MUCH LEFT TO DO BUT
I BELIEVE IN THE REMARKABLE
TALENT ASSEMBLED HERE.
AND I BELIEVE IN OUR STATE.
AND I KNOW THIS TO THE BOTTOM OF
MY HEART.
THE BEST IS YET TO COME THANK
YOU ALL VERY
.
THANK YOU GOVERNOR SOME.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE GOVERNOR
STATE OF THE STATE ADDRESS OF
THE PRINTER THE JOURNAL AS A
SEPARATE APPENDIX.
WE WILL ADJOURN THE JOINT
CONVENTION SIGNING DIED.
WE ARE BACK IN REGULAR SESSION
ANNOUNCEMENTS.
THE SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS WEDNESDAY FEBRUARY
THIRTEENTH CHECK IN SESSION.
THURSDAY FEBRUARY FOURTEENTH
CHECK IN SESSION FRIDAY FEBRUARY
FIFTEENTH FLOOR SESSION AT NINE
AM
.
WHAT?
OTHER ITEMS REMAINING SHOULD BE
PASSED RETAIN ALL MOTIONS BE
CONTINUED.
I AM READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
TO ADJOURN.
MR GLORIA MOVES AND MISS WALDRON
SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL FRIDAY FEBRUARY
FIFTEENTH AT NINE AM.
THE QUORUM CALL IS THAT